[Music]
[Applause]
is espn's emmy award-winning college
football analyst kirk kerb street new
book out called out of the pocket
football fatherhood and college game day
saturdays
he'll be his opening assignment not bad
georgia against clemson number five
versus number three that'll be the
duke's
mayo classic in charlotte also working
with chris fowler again
this year and uh herbie joins us on the
program oh you got ohio state colors on
there hermie
no i got university of dayton colorado
oh okay i like that
do you have any uh maize in blue though
uh i do i do i don't usually go with
that shirt tie combo because i've been
destroyed by
by the lunatic fringe for wearing that
so i tend to
even though i yeah i like that look you
know but i just kind of put it on the
back burner for for a few decades
what's the toughest response you ever
got
to an outfit or
something you said i it just i i think
it was even jim tressel um when i was
doing a game and i always go down in the
field before games and i i you know
despite what fans may think about
announcers we don't always think about
our shirt tie combo color with with the
teams we're covering
and jim trussell said wow
like
i can't believe you're wearing that you
know and i was i didn't even think about
it i looked down and i had a blue shirt
with a yellow tile and i was like
i was like okay mental note never never
wear this combo i guess uh so that was
you know other than that like fan i
worked with brent musberger for years
and i've got ohio state fans would come
up to me and be like i hate must burger
i'd be like
why oh he loves michigan i'm like he
does i've worked with him for eight
years i don't think he like i think he
likes the team that he bets on i don't
think he likes michigan
and they're like
no he always one time he wore a blue
coat and a yellow uh overcoat i mean he
clearly loves michigan
he's the guy that said holy buckeye on
that fourth and one against purdue like
he he loves the game man he's not he's
not in love with michigan but you know
how fans are
if somebody didn't see when eminem came
into the booth with you and brent how
would you how would you describe
eminem's mindset
it's an interesting question and people
or they're not familiar with that need
to google uh google that so he came in
with his his bodyguards it was very
clear that the whole booth had to be
emptied so all the spotters
statisticians everybody had to get out
of the booth it just had to be uh
brent and i in there by the time or he
wouldn't have come into the studio into
the booth so you know he we cleared
everybody out he came in at a break
could not have been any cooler came up
he's like what's up kirk how you doing
man nice to meet you mr musburger wow
it's a great honor like he we're just
sitting there hanging out he put his
headphones on and we were just talking
you know just just just normal
and then he goes man i hate live tv man
and i go oh you kidding me this is this
would be easy and he goes where's the
camera and it's like one of the cameras
in these booths you've seen them and
they're the size of a coke can and
they're just kind of hanging up at the
top and i just kind of pointed to it and
he goes okay cool right there i go yeah
and all of a sudden three two one we're
back and brent starts to talk
and we go from like an overshot of the
big house in ann arbor up to the booth
and all of a sudden
i look over
and he's turned into something i don't
even know what he was he's just all of a
sudden like and brent's like all right
here he is eminem's up here with us and
eminem just starts just
like this goes into this character for
one of his songs and
i was like i was just talking to him
like what what happened you know and he
stayed in that character for
it felt like a minute but it was
probably 15 seconds and then he kind of
snapped out of it and started to do the
interview but man it went it went uh
viral it was everywhere and i started to
think about it because everywhere i went
people were like dude what's up with
them and then you know i hear you are
asking me years later it was on the
today show good morning america
everywhere and what a genius move by him
because he had a new album coming out
and what better way to market that than
to do that prank and it got everybody
talking wait you think he did it you
think he did that on purpose
absolutely absolutely i think he
he went into that berserk uh character
just to have some fun and to create
people to be like what was he high
what's wrong with eminem what was and
all that noise at least made people know
that hey he's got a new album coming out
that's what i think he did i love that
brent goes marshall and then and then he
called him mathers
mathers tell us about the new
mathers tell us about the new album
because
brent is so up on his eminem you know
yeah mathers yeah
yeah
one time brent said on a he he read a
promo he goes oh don't forget uh
next mondays it's a big show he goes
it's uh usher and beyonce will be on the
program
ladies and gentlemen beyonce and i was
like i was like
beyonce yeah it goes
barbie okay thank you
i go listen you're gonna get one name
right
get beyonce you're right she's worth
getting right yeah for sure uh herbie's
got a new book out out of the pocket
football fatherhood and college game day
saturdays toughest thing to write about
in the book was what
um you know you know gene wojciechowski
i was on i did this with tim and just
the fact i had trust with him
i i i wouldn't you know i don't know
what it's like for you as a kid growing
up but went through a lot of stuff i
kind of compartmentalized a lot of that
emotionally um
as a kid and i think just having to
uncover that a little bit going through
you know a lot of dysfunction in my
background with my family and
um
probably
talking candidly about that kind of
being vulnerable and being willing to
talk about it and do a book i'm a guy
that just i'm kind of an introvert i
don't talk about my feelings very often
with people
and so to kind of relive some of that
stuff uh it was definitely the toughest
part and i think throughout the entire
book i i was very self-deprecating very
honest with myself as a person and as an
athlete as a broadcaster
and um i think you know if you're going
to do a book that's probably the only
way you can do it
how important were sports given the
dysfunction in your family
well i you know i think people that have
you know their parents divorced and and
you know in my case my parents remarried
and ended up getting a divorce again i
went to like eight schools in nine years
and i was this shy kid and so
you know
i think
i think people either turn to anger and
resentment and a lot of cases they go to
drugs and and and for me it was sports i
was so lucky you know i'd never had
resentment towards my dad my dad was my
hero and then he was kind of in and out
of my life
i had more of an emptiness like i wanted
more of my dad my dad was a good person
he just didn't get along with my mom
when they got a divorce and it was nasty
for really for the rest of their life
for the most part and so holidays and
all that kind of stuff the rest of our
lives was difficult to manage so
my outlet was always sports you know
watching sports playing sports um
my buddies and and sports were where i
went to escape and just kind of lived in
that world
i don't know what's going on with the
alliance i know they agreed on the
alliance kirby but i don't i don't know
what it means help us understand if you
don't know what it means the only the
only thing that i can think about
is that they're trying to
you know they didn't sign a contract
they're talking about scheduling anytime
anytime
somebody talks about student athletes
you know you got to be leery of what
what's going on here so
they're talking about we we care about
the student athletes well the sec i
think cares about the student athletes
and so i think it's about creating an
alliance for any kind of vote you know
if if we're going to go to a 12 team
playoff the alliance in the corner over
there is like they're whispering in each
other's ear looking across the room at
greg sankey like there's three of us you
might be big and powerful but there's
three of us we get three votes and
they're talking about how they're going
to vote that's the only thing that i can
think of is that they're aligned
against the sec at this point that they
can they can control things in that
remember it's a power five it's out for
now it's at power five conferences and
those three for the for all intents and
purposes if they're aligned
could control whatever decisions are
made moving forward if it continues to
be by a vote with a unanimous vote with
what you need and i think that's the
only thing that i can really think that
that you know they can talk about
scheduling and they can talk about you
know trying to be you know the true you
know model for student athletes and all
that but i think it's really more about
trying to control power of voting moving
forward don't you think we're headed
towards the nfl model here herbie where
there's
32 40 schools
and
you have college football will will make
the schedules
maybe the players get paid um you know
espn fox they come in and they make the
schedules for this that you just you
basically have an nfl model in college
football
i think we're getting closer and closer
to that i think that the game changer
dan was a supreme court ruling
they basically took the knees out of the
ncaa and judge cavanaugh not only with
the ruling he said basically if you come
back here again we're gonna it's gonna
be a lot worse for you and and i think
it made mark emmerd like a week seven to
ten days later he came out publicly and
basically said
well that's a wrap
we're pretty much done
we're pulling back
and uh we're gonna let the conferences
govern things moving forward so i think
that's what got oklahoma and texas and
these you know everything these dominoes
started to fall as everyone's looking at
the future and trying to guess where is
this thing going and maybe what you're
describing is where we're headed you
know i mean
i'm an old school guy i'm a
traditionalist i love college football
you know i love the pageantry of the
sport i hope we don't lose that but the
reality is this thing is out of control
we we're at a crossroads uh with college
football right now at the highest level
and we've got decision makers right now
that aren't getting along and they're
the ones that are supposed to be leading
together and they're not and so this is
nasty it's it's not even close to being
done at some point we'll get to you know
the worst that it has to offer um and
then maybe the dust will settle we'll be
able to move forward but right now we're
not close to that i can't help but think
of name image and likeness with what
happened to ohio state
and getting tattoos
where
so could they do that now if somebody
wanted to give
one of their jerseys or whatever it
might be hey i i got this at the rose
bowl and uh i'm i'm gonna barter that to
get tattoos
i don't know i don't know that my
understanding of name image and likeness
is you can use your name image or
likeness for whether it's a you know
simple thing like tweeting something out
for on behalf of a company or you know
doing commercials uh for a local car
dealer or pizza dealer whatever it might
be i don't know if you can partner to
try to say hey here's here's a jersey
that i wore in the rose bowl can i can i
have a free tattoo i don't know i i that
that that's this this stuff is just too
new
uh for me to know of whether or not that
is legit and same thing with reggie bush
i've heard a lot of people say you know
this is unfair reggie bush should be
reinstated and i'm thinking
that was like from what i remember about
reggie bush that was an agent that had a
marketing team that provided money for
his family that's a different set of
circumstances than if reggie bush did a
commercial for somebody and got paid
that would be different that would be
allowed today but like an agent paying
you money is not cool like that that
still can't happen
would you give reggie bush's heisman
back
um
yeah i i think the whole thing is kind
of silly i mean reggie bush i was asked
the other day
um
who are the greatest college football
players i've ever covered or ever seen
you know since i've been doing this and
the first name that came to mind was
michael vick
just because of people forget people
maybe remember him as a as a pro
and some of the stuff he got into i
remember him playing at lane stadium you
know at virginia tech and doing things
that i didn't know you were allowed to
do as a quarterback it was just unheard
of to see that in person
and then the other guy's reggie bush i
mean reggie bush from the very first
time i saw him carry the ball as a young
player
um yeah he he would jump in the air and
land and hit the ground like if you're
playing a video game and you had a turbo
button like he would hit go in the air
land and somehow hit his turbo button
when he landed and just be gone and just
spectacular so i i hate that he got
caught up in whatever it was he got
caught up in but uh to me i would i
would definitely provide him with his
heisman and he should be around usc
football as often as he can be around
how surprised were you that urban meyer
decided to coach again and coach in the
nfl
well i i was surprised you know i think
i think the uh you know watching him on
the sidelines you remember when ohio
state was playing in his last year how
many times did we see him like
holding his head and taking a knee and
like almost looked like he was getting
dizzy um i don't i don't i thought man
this might be this might be it for him
um and i don't know what happened i
haven't spoken with him about why now
about his health and i know that he's
always had a calling to want to get back
in but um he must feel as far as his
doctors with that cyst must be okay i
watched him the other night
and he looks still you know he can't
help but he's so competitive he's not
like a coach like tom landry that just
kind of sits there and watches the game
i mean he's he's like
his blood is boiling on the sidelines is
and it's going to be a long year you
know with jacksonville and he's going to
have to learn to somehow
let those emotions uh to the side
because that offensive line is is going
to allow some hits on his franchise
quarterback this year give me a sneaky
team not in the top 10
that could be
in the final four at the end of the year
well the one i'll give you that's first
in the top 10 is cincinnati and how do
you how do you get into the playoff
because we've not seen that if you're a
group of five team
boise state used to flirt with the bcs
because they would have a virginia tech
who was a top ten opponent they'd have a
georgia who was a top ten opponent they
would win those games and they would
have a shot at the end to try to get in
there
i think with indiana or with cincinnati
they play at indiana who's a top 15 team
this year and they play in south bend
those are non-conference games for
cincinnati remember how they played
against george in the sugar bowl they
really outplayed georgia they just
couldn't close the deal and they lost
the game but they were really
competitive i think they they scored
some points there as far as respect so
cincinnati is a team that i think could
actually break into the top four if in
fact they win against indiana and notre
dame on the road then they'd have to win
the american uh outside of that um i
would say
i would give you
uh let's say wisconsin could be maybe a
surprise team they had a down year a
year ago
uh they they seem to be a team that
could be on the bounce i think the
winner actually the penn state wisconsin
game they open up by the way that's a
tough opener in college football uh
whoever wins that game i think could
bounce and have a legitimate shot to get
it up into the top ten pretty quickly
good luck with the book and uh we'll be
watching uh opening opening night it'll
be georgia versus clemson and that'll be
uh the
duke's mayo classic september the fourth
year on abc uh hey great to talk to you
again herbie thank you buddy all right
matters yeah it matters
thank you herbie